[Musik]
klimakleber gefährden Menschenleben der
Bund bewilligt neue Milliardenhilfen
Flüchtlinge und die FDP macht den Grünen
in der Atomkraftwerk Frage schwere
Vorwürfe viel Diskussionen Zündstoff in
der Luft herzlich willkommen bei Film
nach acht mit diesen Gästen ex-regierung
Sprecher und Deutschlands
Kommunikationsexperte Nummer eins
belaander selbstverständlich auch früh
nach acht Stammgast schön dass du da
bist Bela du bist heute Abend über die
Meinungsfreiheit sprechen ich bin
gespannt auch mit von Empathie Professor
Dr Herfried Münkler erst
Politikwissenschaftler und Autor sein
Thema heute Abend unsere Demokratie ist
in Gefahr gewaltsprävention Berater und
sozialaktivist Carsten Stahl ihn
beschäftigt die von ihm gespürte Armut
und Verzweiflung in diesem Land
Journalist und Ressortleiter beim
politischen Magazin Cicero deine Gräber
hat seine eigenen Recherchen heute abend
mitgebracht sie zeigen wie Robert Habeck
und Steffi Lemke die deutschen
Kernkraftwerke verzögert und blockiert
haben ich bin sehr gespannt andere
weniger nette politische Kommentatoren
würden sogar allerdings beim pH-Wert von
einer Lüge am Bürger sprechen ich bin
gespannt wie ihr Gräber später einordnet
mein Thema heute Abend sind aber die
klimakleber ich nenne sie eher
klimakriminelle denn die gefährden
Menschenleben ich wähle das Wort
klimakriminelle hier sehr sehr bewusst
denn die klimakleber geben für mich viel
zu weit ich finde ja dass allein dieses
Wort die Aktivitäten dieser Bewegung
verniedlicht Klima Kleber erinnert mich
immer an eine Aktivität im Kindergarten
mit roten Buntstift und grünen Bäumen wo
klimazeichnung aufgeklebt werden wir
müssen sie endlich als das bezeichnen
was sie sind Kriminelle denn wer Straßen
blockiert indem er sich an den Boden
klebt hilft nicht dem Klima sondern
gefährdet Menschenleben wie es jetzt
gerade hier in Berlin leider passiert
ist die ökoextremisten haben durch eine
klebeblockade auf der Stadtautobahn ein
Stau verursacht und so die Rettung einer
Schwerverletzten gefährdet ein dringend
benötigtes Spezialfahrzeug konnte nicht
rechtzeitig zu der Radfahrerin gelangen
jetzt kämpft die Frau um ihr Leben die
Verantwortlichen gehören für mich ins
Gefängnis und ich würde gerne die Runde
eröffnen mit Carsten Stahl ob er mir
zustimmt oder sagt nein die gehören
nicht ins Gefängnis
soll ich die Handschellen rausholen wir
gehen auf die Straße und wir zeigen mal
was Aktivismus bedeutet ich bin seit
neun Jahren im Kinderschutz und
Kinderschutz Aktivist ich habe noch nie
in der Zeit in irgendeiner Weise
Menschenleben gefährdet mich irgendwo
angeklebt irgendwelche Straßenblock
haben gemacht
Rettungsfahrzeuge daran gehindert
Menschenleben zu schützen und zu
bewahren und wenn ich dann noch höre
dass ich jemand hinstellt einer der dir
Fürsprecher ist und sagt shit happens
wir sind wir sind im klimakampf und ich
im klimakuscheln da sah ich Herr Müller
tun sie mir gefallen halten Sie die
Fresse halten Sie einfach die Fresse
wenn sie keine Ahnung haben und wenn sie
sich profilieren wollen suchen sich
einen Job machen sie was vernünftig und
so scheiße Schaufeln aber zählen sie
nicht so viel Scheiße es ist unfassbar
weil ihr den Menschen in diesem Land
zumutet mit eurer grünen Ideologie und
eurem grünen Wahnsinn unser Land hier in
Geiselhaft zu nehmen statt einer aber
jetzt Menschenleben zu gefährden oder
hier wieder bei den Dinosauriern Kindern
mit zu missbrauchen in eure Ideologie
mit einzuspannen es reicht
sonst bin ich vielleicht auch mal der
Meinung gehen wir mit unseren Aktivisten
auf die Straße und Schaufeln vielleicht
mal ein bisschen Scheiße Weg aus den ja
Gehweg Rinnen also zusammengefasst die
sollten jetzt zu und ich persönlich sage
das Problem ist ja eins die kommen ja
meistens ausreichend Haushalten
Geldstrafen werden die gar nicht
ausmachen wenn selbst aussprechen 10.000
Euro bezahlt Papi oder Mami aber wenn
man so zu drei Monaten Haft vielleicht
mal wegsperren zum Latin putzen ja dann
ist das vielleicht unangenehm wie haben
Sie denn schon gejammert als VW oder
Porsche das Licht ausgemacht hat und
denn die Heizung ausgeschaltet hat und
dann durfte nicht auf toilettchen oh
unsere luxusklimaaktivisten fandet nicht
schick aber solange unsere Politik auf
dem linken und dem grünen Auge blind ist
und sie verharmlosen so wie du das
gesagt hast werden sie weitermachen sich
animiertüren und sie werden sich
formieren und immer weitermachen ich
sage es reicht das sind Kriminelle wir
Menschen Leben gefährdet gehört ins
Gefängnis
Carsten Stahl hat ja Herrn Müller wehnt
ich weiß nicht ob jeder das weiß also
dieser Tweet von dem du gesprochen hast
Carsten der kommt ja von Tacho Müller
das ist so seit 20 Jahren er selber
bezeichnet sich so als Vorreiter dieser
ganzen Aktivisten Szene muss jetzt so
ein bisschen ist auch in die Jahre
gekommen muss gucken wo er bleibt weil
natürlich die lebensmaß und die anderen
Luisa Neubauer kam ihm da das Wasser ab
deswegen
radikalisiert er sich immer mehr und man
kann es ja alles nachgucken im Internet
es gibt vor einem Jahr ein
entsprechendes Youtube-Video aus
Frankfurt wo er da ganz genau die
Kaskade des Protestes durch exerziert
und sagt sogar dass diese Bewegung
in Kauf nimmt Polizisten zu provozieren
um über den Polizisten die Ausschreitung
der Polizisten wiederum in die Medien zu
kommen und ihre Sachen dann eben in den
Medien vorbringen zu können also das ist
eine Kaskade wir da wenn Sie sich das
Video anguckt ab ungefähr Minute 15 da
auf wird das ist schon irre und vor Zeit
hat genau dieser gleiche Tag your client
gesprochen von der grünen RAF und fand
das irgendwie ganz witzig und da wird es
tatsächlich ein bisschen gefährlich weil
das werden auch die Grünen die meisten
zumindest nicht wollen in diese Ecke
gesteckt zu werden aber es ist natürlich
etwas was hochgefährlich ist weil
meistens beginnt es ja gerade wenn es um
ein höheres gut geht und den Kampf für
Demokratie im positiven den Kampf gegen
vermeintliche Mächten den Vietnamkrieg
oder sonst was da geht es mal los mit
dem farbein mit dem Farbbeutel dann
beginnt mit irgendwelchen Sachen gegen
Gemälde man klebt sich an aber der
Schritt wenn man dann von der grünen RF
spricht zu weiterer Radikalisierung ist
zumindest in der Vergangenheit für ein
Teil dieser Gruppierung immer der
nächste Schritt gewesen und da wird es
dann wirklich auf genauso wie bei
solchen Tweets die wir von ihm gesehen
haben politische Bewegung sprechen würde
ich sie gerne einmal fragen Herr Münkler
wie kommt es denn zu dieser politischen
Bewegung dieser Klimabewegung und wie
weit werden die gehen
wie weit sie gehen werden dass lässt
sich schlecht Voraussagen meine es kann
ja sein dass sie jetzt gewissermaßen das
Unheil dass sie da angerichtet haben als
eine Art Stoppschild begreifen aber das
entscheidende glaube ich liegt auf einer
anderen Ebene sie sind für sozusagen das
Spiegelbild des Populismus sie halten
sich nämlich ja letzten Endes für eine
avantgardistische Elite sie glauben sie
wissen mehr sie müssen sich nicht auf
den Prozess der Demokratie nämlich
Kompromissbildung einlassen sondern
erheben für sich einen Anspruch
eigentlich absoluten bestens nicht und
insofern kann man sagen das sind keine
Freunde der Demokratie auch in der Art
wie sie auftreten sondern sie können
eher auf Sicht gefährlich für sie werden
und alles schon etwas von einer
religiösen Bewegung so etwas wie einer
Sekte wenn man sagt dass sie sich
eigentlich gar nicht an der
demokratiebildung dann beteiligen wollen
ja ja ich meine sozusagen absolutes
Wissen ist ja in Regel wissen dass man
über Propheten oder andere hat und das
auch nicht zur Disposition gestellt
werden kann und auch nicht
kompromissfähig ist in der Praxis und
von daher
kann man sagen das hebelt die Demokratie
von ihrem Grundverständnis her aus und
insofern glaube ich dass man das Problem
jetzt nicht angeht indem man sagt das
sind Kriminelle das muss der Rechtsstaat
irgendeiner Weise klären das ist nicht
unsere Sache das zu entscheiden
sondern klimakleber nicht etwas niedlich
ich finde klimakleber dafür dass jetzt
ein Menschenleben gefährdet wurde
Straßen blockiert werden Menschen nicht
und dementsprechend auch Rettungswagen
durchkommen ihres Berufsstandes möchte
Journalisten die sozusagen so eine
Bezeichnung offenbar wegen der
Alliteration
[Musik]
ja straßenblockierer zunächst einmal
nicht zu einer richtigen Alliteration
wird es erst bei drei kritische
klimakleber sowas
aufhören
jetzt gut die kleben sich nun mal fest
womit ich immer ein Problem habe ist
dass sie immer als Aktivisten als
klimaaktivisten bezeichnet werden was
sie zwar auch sind aber es sind auch vor
allen Dingen Extremisten und da sehe ich
ein großes Problem dass unser Staat in
weiten Teilen gerade in Berlin ist es zu
spüren der Berliner Senat fast diese
sogenannten Aktivisten mit
Samthandschuhen an im wahrsten Sinne des
Wortes den werden ja mit Speiseöl nahezu
zärtlich dann die die Finger vom Asphalt
geholt während dann Leute im Stau warten
die auf dem wichtigen Termin müssen oder
eventuell sogar jemandem das Leben
retten müssen Sie vorschlagen die
abgelöst werden ich habe in einem
anderen Publikation aus ihrem Haus der
Berliner Boulevardzeitung BZ vorhin
einen Artikel gelesen der wurden dir als
ökoextremisten bezeichnet das sind sie
es sind Linksextremisten auch weil sie
auch das öko ist für die auch nur ein
Vorwand um letztendlich die Abschaffung
des Kapitalismus anzustreben und mit
Demokratie haben die wirklich nichts am
Hut wenn der gleiche Protest von rechts
käme und sich zum Beispiel etwa gegen
die unkontrollierte Migration richten
würde was meinen Sie wie schnell die von
den Straßen weg wären und zu was für
Gefängnisstrafen die fördert werden will
das wäre ganz klar sind Linksextremisten
für sie genauso schlimm wie
Rechtsextremisten
weil es ist einfach nicht dasselbe in
gewissen Ausprägungen natürlich ähnelt
sich dann wieder nämlich dass sie
nämlich die Demokratie letztendlich
abschaffen wollen die einen wollen
vielleicht den Führerstand die anderen
die kommunistische was weiß ich finde es
Rede Republik und setzen dafür auch
Gewalt als legitimes Mittel ein und das
ist für mich der Unterschied sobald man
darf sich streiten man darf
unterschiedlicher Meinung sein man darf
auch das System überwinden oder
abschaffen wollen das muss man auch
können Demokratie aber sobald man dazu
Gewalt einsetzt und dazu zählt auch so
eine Blockade das würde ich auch als
Gewalt erzählen man sieht es in den
Auswirkungen dann muss Schluss sein und
dann muss der Rechtsstaat ganz
wirklich ganz stark dagegen vorgehen
damit Leute wie sie ich verstehe ihre
Aufregung und man sieht es ihnen auch an
dass sie durchaus in der Lage wären mit
den Leuten fertig zu werden aber genau
das darf ja nicht passieren das wäre
selbst Justiz und das wollen wir Gottes
Stimme ist die Polizei soll das machen
die Polizei ist ja nicht vor Ort sie ist
Polizei sind die vor Ort die geben sich
da fest und dann haben sie da Menschen
und nicht jeder reagiert gleich und wenn
dann ja jemand sitzt so wie letztens der
dann verbal entglitten ist und sein Kind
dann genommen ist und die Mutter ist
gefahren und er hat die jetzt wird
wortwillig uns jetzt mal einer sparen
gesagt hat der da kann und das wird und
das kann ich halt nur an so ich komme
aus einer aus einer Gewalt Zeit ich
komme aus Berlin Neukölln ich habe viele
Dinge erlebt man sieht mir das mit
Sicherheit auch an und viele wissen das
auch und ich merke ja wie diese Grenzen
immer mehr schwinden und die Leute immer
wieder gewaltbereiter sind und das jetzt
in der Zeit wo die sowieso alles in die
Schnauze voll haben durch die Politik
und durch die ganzen Entbehrung
zweieinhalb Jahre Pandemie jetzt das es
brodelt und jetzt kleben die sich da auf
Kniehöhe und Fußballplatz hö fest
verstehen sie ich sehe das schon dass
das passieren wird und dann wird uns
alles was extrem ist ob glücksfilm
Gewalt extrem links extrem rechts extrem
egal wie ist immer gefährlich und das
sind so einer Zeit wenn man seine Ziele
durchsetzen möchte dann gibt es andere
Möglichkeiten ich mache seit neun Jahren
Aktivismus ich habe sowas noch nicht
gebracht und bei mir geht es um Kinder
und dann stellen sie sich hin und sagen
es geht um die Zukunft der Kinder die
gleichen Herren und Damen habe ich noch
nie aufschreiben hören dass im Jahr
offiziell fast 20.000 Kinder missbraucht
werden da hört die nicht auf schreien
aber sie nehmen Kinder an die Hand und
missbrauchen sie benutzen sie für ihren
Idealismus der soweit geht Klima alles
wunderbar müssen wir mal tun aber nicht
auf die Art und Weise wenn wir jetzt die
These mit einem mit einer Lösung beenden
wollen Bela was würdest du denn der
Regierung raten vielleicht sogar auch in
der Kommunikation mit den
klimaextremisten ökoextremisten naja ich
meine es bringt sicherlich nichts gut
den gut zu reden weil
wie gesagt ich kann in jedem raten
schaut man sich das an dieses Video von
Tacho kleinen ist klar dass das einer
Strategie folgt und die Strategie ist
eben durch solche Maßnahmen
Aufmerksamkeit zu generieren zum Teil
auch nicht bei allen sicherlich Polizei
zu provozieren um die Taten der Polizei
dann eben entsprechend aufzunehmen und
dann über den den die Erregung über
diese Missetaten der Polizei sich selbst
ins Gespräch zu bringen ist da und Klein
erklärt also folgt es einer Methode
nicht bei allen es gibt auch das müssen
wir auch sagen hast bei denen die dabei
sind auch ein paar die denken wirklich
morgen geht die Welt unter wenn ich mich
jetzt hier nicht festklebe das gibt es
auch aber ich würde sagen du hast
gefragt nach den Methoden ich würde hier
hart durchgreifen weil jede klebeaktion
mehr erhöht die
Akzeptanz von diesen Aktionen die wird
und motiviert natürlich weiteres zu tun
wir werden weiter solche Dinge sehen wie
wir gesehen haben dass Rettungswagen
nicht durchkommen und dergleichen ist es
nicht gut wenn wir einfach sagen okay
berechtigtes ansehen kleben wir euch mal
da wieder ab
wünscht sich Carsten Stahl das
durchgegriffen wird und zwar das etwas
gegen die Verarmung der Menschen in
Deutschland getan wird dass es ihre
Teesorte hat wie viele ja vielleicht
wissen aus der dir ein oder andere der
mich jetzt nicht kennt setze ich mich
seit vielen Jahren für gegen Missstände
in unserem Land ein und bin für viele
ein Sprachrohr Millionen Menschen hör
mir zu und fühlen sich durch das was ich
sage auch wenn ich es eher
unkonventionell sage verstanden und
abgeholt ich kriege sehr viele E-Mails
und ich habe jetzt hier einfach mal ein
paar Ausschnitte dazu mitgebracht ich
nehme jetzt hier mal die die ich am
wirklich auch am warnendsten für uns
alle finden sollte Vater mit einem
Monatseinkommen von 2200 Euro netto
schreibt wir sind vier Personen im
Haushalt meine Frau arbeitet auch
Teilzeit wie ich ich arbeite fast jeden
Tag 24 Stunden meine Familie und ich
haben natürlich Angst vor dem was
passiert ich kann noch nicht mal einen
Ausflug von 410 € leisten für meinen
Sohn also einen so einen Klassenausflug
ja ich weiß nicht mehr weiter manchmal
habe ich gedacht mein Leben zu beenden
doch ich kann meine Familie nicht im
Stich lassen wenn wir diese Weg so
weitergehen mit einer Politik die nur
ihren Interessen und Ideologien voll
werden wir noch nie da gewesene
suizid-zahlen haben bis hin das
Familienväter oder auch Mütter die
Familie vielleicht mit in den Tod nehmen
das sind wenn ich kriege hunderte von so
einem E-Mails ganz besonders nach
Auftritten bei euch bekomme ich solche
Dinge auch in euren Kommentaren tausende
von Zuschriften die da drin stehen das
ist der tägliche die tägliche
Traurigkeit die tägliche Realität und da
kam ich so viele ich kann hier einige
davon Vorlesen die wirklich schlimm sind
alle deine körperlicher Behinderter
Vater von dreijährigen Sohn schreibt ich
habe seit einem Monat nichts Warmes mehr
gegessen es wird täglich nicht mehr als
ein Brötchen und wasche mich nur noch
mit dem Lappen am Waschbecken um Kosten
zu sparen damit mein Sohn der drei Jahre
ist kein Hunger mehr leidet sich auf
letztens gemacht in grün und hier ist
das ganze Ding noch mal orange lieber
Herr Kretschmer lieber Steinmeier lieber
Bundesregierung steckt euch eure
Waschlappen sonst vorhanden und sorgt
dafür dass die Menschen in unserem Land
solche Dinge nicht erleiden müssen
solche Schmerzen und solche Leute nicht
erfahren müssen das kann nicht sein dass
wir in unserem reichen Land
nicht dafür schaffen dass unsere Bürger
leben wollen und vor allen Dingen auch
existieren können wir verschenken Geld
in aller Welt und bei uns leiden
Menschen und ihr baut euren Kanzler
trotz Bau ihre potenzverlängerung da
weiter schämt ihr euch nicht in Grund
und Boden ich kann mich gar nicht so
viel Fremdschäden und im Strahl kotzen
wenn ich das alles sehe und dieser
Verzweiflung hier höre und das macht
mich wütend
es Steiger ist natürlich schockierende
Beispiele haben sie die Menschen auch
getroffen also es ist sie schreiben mir
manchmal ja auch anonym weil sie ja
nicht gewissen manche halten mit Namen
Telefonnummer das ist teilweise ja so
also das oft steht ja auch dabei wir
danken Ihnen dass Sie für uns sprechen
oder das was sie sagen in der Art der
Markt für den ein oder anderen jetzt für
sie hat publiziert vielleicht ein
bisschen kurios sein wie ich spreche
aber viele Menschen spüren halt bei mir
diese Wut diese Wut jetzt betrifft nicht
nicht vielleicht wie jeden von denen
weil ich vielleicht innerhalb
gesellschaftlich anderen Positionen
vielleicht sein mag aber egal wie gut es
mir geht oder wie schlecht es mir geht
es ist meine Aufgabe und meine Pflicht
als Vorbild für Millionen von Menschen
und als Bürger und Vater an diesem Land
auch für die Menschen die Stimme zu
erheben dient nicht so gut gestellt sind
und die den schwächer geht ich frag mich
bloß ich bin nicht Innenminister nicht
Bundeskanzler und auch sonst niemand von
den Würdenträgern die dafür die Kohle
bekommen sondern die bekommen ihre
Forderung an die Würdenträger wie Sie
sehen erstmal fängt man in der Krise an
seinen Charakter zu beweisen das hat der
beste ever gesagt ja so und ich wurde
noch mal anfangen bei unseren Herrn der
jeden Tag vergesst wahrscheinlich auch
wie er heißt dass er anfängt zu sagen
also in so einer Krise können wir nicht
für 777 Millionen Euro den Kanzler Bau
weitermachen das brauche ich nicht wir
stoppen Ding ja auch wenn die
Bundesregierung da fordert angefangen
hat sind wir ein Mann Signalen Zeichen
und dann sollte man vielleicht vor sie
ja vorsichtiger mit dem Geld was man so
verteilt auf der ganzen Welt und für
Dinge ein bisschen überlegen bietet sich
für die Menschen anfühlt die halt solche
Dinge da schreiben die die kleinsten
Dinge nicht mehr machen können man
sollte von seiner Wolke Sieben aus
seiner Wand blitzblase mal rauskommen
und einfach mal zwischen die Bürgern
also zum lösungsvorschlagen sie sind
also für Höheres Hartz IV für höhere
Grundsicherung für Höheres aufstocken
das würden sie fordern dass mehr Geld an
die Bürger ausgeschaltet ich glaube es
wäre schon mal glaube ich wichtig dass
man halt guckt so wie ich die Politiker
auch gemacht haben sie haben sich ja z.B
Europaparlament um die Inflationsrate
ihre Gehälter erhöht ja also wenn man
das mal so sieht oder sich überhaupt
ihre transferiert es wäre doch schon mal
wichtig dass wir natürlich auch das
Ausgleichen natürlich muss man gucken
denn es sollte schon noch wichtig in
unserem Land sein dass es sich lohnt
arbeiten zu gehen denn wenn ich jetzt
höre dass bestimmte Bürgergeld auf
einmal so laufen sollen dass die Leute
sagen bin ich bekloppt und soll ich noch
arbeiten gehen die bezahlen mein Strom
mein Gas meine Miete da geht jeder der
arbeiten jeden Tag weniger dann haben
wir beide Leute die ja nicht mehr
arbeiten gehen der darf auch nicht sein
gibt's das Aufstocken beispielsweise
damit das schon auf einem Niveau bleibt
das arbeiten gehen und das Bürgergeld
okay also wir müssen versuchen
aufzufangen und selbst wenn es schwer
genau ich kann mich nicht als als als
als oberste Staatsoberhaupt hinstellen
eine große Ansprache halten wo übrigens
kein Bundesregierung Mitglied anwesend
ist wie erbärmlich und peinlich und dann
sagen wir müssen uns auf harte raue
Jahre ein einstellen und selber aber
keine Opfer und Entbehrung bringen große
Töne spucken spucken und sich heute sich
da hinstellen und von uns Entbehrung
erwarten und selber nicht hingehen bitte
Herr Steinmeier lassen Sie uns gemeinsam
zu diesen Menschen gehen und wenn Sie
schon dabei kein Geld Zeit zu
verschenken wie wäreste mal ein bisschen
Geld führt Aartal was nämlich da brach
liegt und wo die Menschen bis heute
nicht bekommen haben wo so alle größte
betone gespuckt haben wie es da war also
Fotos gemacht jetzt ist für alle die
älter nur für die Menschen in unserem
Land nicht zumindestens nicht so spürbar
dass sie nicht diese Dinger bekommen und
der traurig ist ich glaube dass sie
schon so verzweifelt sind dass sie ja
nicht mehr Familienministerin und soweit
Anschreiben sondern eher die
Bild-Zeitung oder mich oder andere
Organisation weil sie den schon lange
nicht mehr vertrauen
wie steht es um die Armut in unserem
Land naja gut das Problem ist wir waren
eine Industriegesellschaft und in der
Industriegesellschaft ist die Fähigkeit
der abhängig Beschäftigten ihre
Interessen zur Geltung zu bringen sich
zu organisieren sehr viel größer als in
einer Dienstleistungsgesellschaft
insofern fand ich das
grundsätzlich eine bemerkenswerte
Leistung des ersten und zweiten
Kabinetts Schröder Fischer dass sie im
Unterschied zu dem englischen
Entwicklungsweg Maggie fatcher sozusagen
voll auf Dienstleistungsgesellschaft zu
gehen versucht haben industrielle Kerne
bei uns aufrecht zu erhalten
man kann über die harzrehformen ja
streiten ob das in dieser Hinsicht klug
war oder weniger klug war jedenfalls das
war die Absicht dabei und das kann man
sagen ist sozusagen ein
ursozialdemokratisches anlegen
nun zeigt sich aber natürlich in der
internationalen Konkurrenz
Globalisierung mit wem auch immer ist es
nicht so leicht
Industrie aufrecht zu erhalten
jedenfalls dann wenn die Produkte die
man herstellt viel zu teuer sind um sich
auf den Weltmarkt behaupten zu können
und insofern würde ich Unterschied zu
Herrn Stahl eher da ansetzen zu
überlegen in welcher Weise sind wir in
der Lage auch die Politik in der Lage
gesellschaftliche Verhältnisse zu
schaffen in denen entsprechende
Arbeitsmöglichkeiten für die Leute da
sind so dass Sie also letzten Endes
nicht von Wohltaten von wem auch immer
dem Staat oder
Herr Steinmeier persönlich und derlei
mehr man kennt ja sozusagen diese
Vorgänge wo Politiker sich gerne
inszenieren unter den Bedürftigen unter
dem Betroffenen der Leimer oder mit
Steuergeldern Weihnachtsmann Spielen der
Weihnachtsmann Spielen von mir aus auch
das
Problem ist es muss denn hinterher
natürlich alles vernünftig organisiert
werden und rechtlich so gefasst werden
das ist nicht bei den falschen ankommt
und wir haben ja in den letzten Jahren
oft genug also in der Frage der Pandemie
etwa erlebt dass schlampig gemachte
Gesetze Ausführungsbestimmungen dazu
führen das Geld quasi rausgeschmissen
worden es irgendwo hin in dunklen
Kanälen versickert und der Leim ja das
ist sicherlich mit einer der Gründe
warum man nicht im Einzelfall helfen
kann aus der Politik was ist eher eine
Sache der caritativen Organisationen
sondern dass man Rahmenbedingungen
schaffen muss in denen die Menschen die
Chance haben ein selbstbestimmtes Leben
zu führen indem sie auch die Anerkennung
für sich bekommen nicht ich bin abhängig
ich muss andere um etwas bitten sondern
ich selber schaffe das mich aus dem
Dreck herauszuarbeiten
ich finde sie sind da gar nicht so
auseinander denn was ich auch nicht mehr
hören kann ist diese ich meine gut bin
natürlich privilegierter und so aber
trotzdem kann ich es nicht mehr hören
dieses ewige müssten den Gürtel enger
schneiden langsamer fahren auf der
Autobahn um Sprit zu sparen okay Heizung
runter drehen meint wegen ist ja auch
okay also all diese Maßnahmen gut aber
ohne diese Gänge Leib bitte aber vor
allen Dingens doch um folgendes und sie
haben es erwähnt wir sind durch diese
Reform immer noch ein Land mit den
größten industriellen Kernen in
Deutschland bis jetzt und wir haben
einen Wirtschafts- und Klima Minister
aber bitte in dieser Reihenfolge
Wirtschaft und Klima und vielleicht ist
es mal Zeit sich um die Wirtschaft zu
kümmern und zu gucken wie kann ich es
schaffen dass ich dass ich Unternehmen
davon abhalte nach China zu gehen wie
jetzt BASF dass ich es gibt verlockende
Angebote auch aus den USA für viele
viele Unternehmen wo Unternehmen weniger
Steuern zahlen weniger Energiepreise
bezahlen und dergleichen sich damit
darum zu kümmern also diese
industriellen Kerne ist ja immer noch
gibt in Europa gerade in Deutschland zu
bewahren um den Menschen eben auch
Arbeit zu geben und sie eben nicht in
Hartz IV zu bringen oder das Bürgergeld
zu kassieren dass ich übrigens die genau
die gleichen Probleme und dann geht sie
auch weiter Gründerin Gründer haben
jetzt gerade den Finanzminister
geschrieben haben gesagt wo sind denn
hier die Innovation wo sind die
Beteiligungsmöglichkeiten er sagt ja ich
kümmere mich darum aber all das hören
wir doch schon lange wo ist der
Bürokratieabbau den wir seit 20 Jahren
brauchen wo die wirkliche
ganztagsschulbetreuung wo gibt es die
Chancengleichheit mittlerweile in den
Schulen für Kinder gibt es doch auch
nicht mehr
also es gibt einen wirklich Haufen von
Problemen aber für mich fängt es an in
der Wirtschaft und darum tatsächlich
sich um die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit und die
Möglichkeit zu kümmern vom Steuerrecht
hin bis zur Bürgerbeteiligung auch in
Unternehmen an gewinnen auch
entsprechend dann auch und da gibt es
noch ganz viel zu tun Wirtschaft nicht
als Feind zu sehen sondern als das was
Menschen in die Möglichkeit versetzen
gutes Einkommen zu haben das wünsche ich
mir Herr Gräber ist vielleicht schuld
Anspruchshaltung der Staat würde schon
richten nicht essen der corona-pandemie
wurde es ja sehr auf den Start alles
ausgelegt der Start der starke Start der
aber natürlich nicht immer zielgerichtet
agiert ich glaube es ist in Deutschland
traditionell bei uns und von der SPD
entschuldigung wenn ich ihre Partei da
jetzt in Haftung nehme aber speziell von
der SPD ist schon dieses der kümmernde
Staat der der Vater Staat der sich um
alle Probleme kümmert was auch in
Deutschland glaube ich vieles auch
befriedet hat also wir leben Gott sei
immer noch in einem Land wo auch die
sozialen
Konflikte natürlich da sind weil es sich
natürlich auseinander entwickelt aber
wenn man in in Länder wie wie die USA
oder sowas guckt wo das viel viel
stärker auseinander geht da kann man ja
auch froh sein dass es bei uns eben
nicht so ist trotzdem steckt dahinter
was was man sich auch leisten können
muss und diesen Sozialstaat den wir bei
uns haben den auch jeder
selbstverständlich in Anspruch nimmt und
sofort dann wenn es wirtschaftliche
Probleme gibt muss der Staat die
Kaufhäuser retten er muss er muss auf
denen die Energiekosten jetzt drücken er
muss bei Corona muss er die Lockdown
Ausfälle finanzieren das Geld muss ja
auch irgendwo herkommen und da kommen
wir zu dem Punkt der der Wirtschaft und
der Industrie wir sind gerade mittendrin
in einer hochgefährlichen Phase wo wir
dabei sind den Kern unseres Wohlstands
zu verlieren und zwar nicht nur wie bei
vergangenen Krisen mal durch den Tal zu
gehen dann geht es wieder aufwärts nee
wir sind dabei dass wir wirklich was
eigentlich was kaputt machen was in
Jahrzehnten nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
ja aufgebaut wurde und da habe ich große
Sorgen dafür und deswegen nehme ich auch
Herrn Habig da kommen wir später sein
agieren in diesem speziellen Segment der
Energiepolitik was aber ein sehr
wichtiges ist nämlich ihm da auch auch
sehr sehr übel ich halte das für hoch
hochgefährlich was was die
Bundesregierung da gerade treibt wenn
wir noch einmal bei der anfangsthese von
Herrn Stahl bleiben hätte ich noch eine
Frage an Sie wieso funktioniert es denn
nicht wir sind ja einer Meinung mit der
Anspruchshaltung und
aber Kinderarmut zu bekämpfen das hat
sich ja nicht nur die SPD sondern
eigentlich alle Parteien immer auf die
Fahne eigentlich geschrieben warum
funktioniert das nicht wirklich und das
nicht erst seit fünf Jahren sollen ja
eigentlich seit Jahrzehnten ist daher
keine große Verbesserung eingetreten
naja ich meine Sozialwissenschaftler
könnte ich jetzt natürlich sagen das hat
auch was mit den veränderten
Lebensentwürfen von Menschen zu tun also
dem Wachstum der Anzahl der
Alleinerziehenden bei denen natürlich
die materiellen Probleme eskalieren
doch den 50er 60er 70er Jahren war halt
die zwei elternfamilie der Regelfall
schauen Sie sich bestimmten Bereichen
die Veränderung das ja der Lebensführung
an dann bekommen sie natürlich schon
eine Vorstellung davon wie so etwas auch
passiert wie sich so etwas entwickelt
nun steht man dafür ein Problem nämlich
zu sagen es ist die freie Entscheidung
eines jeden Menschen aber ein Kind haben
will oder nicht und ob er mit einem
Vater oder dieser Mutter zusammenleben
will oder nicht
jetzt kommt aber das Problem hinzu dass
in gewisser Hinsicht ja auch Ihr Problem
war in der Frage Bürgergeld naja da gibt
es aber dann auch welche die die
sozialen Netze sozusagen ausnutzen mir
ist gut erinnere ich als unsere Tochter
Handball gespielt hat der hat ziemlich
gut Handball gespielt
da gab es Eltern drumherum die waren
jünger als ich ja gehört es ja so
Handwerker waren alle arbeitslos im
Wedding und alle arbeitslos haben aber
natürlich alle schwarz gearbeitet nicht
dann haben sich sozusagen der
unterhalten was sie für Ansprüche an den
Staat haben und der Leim mehr und so
eine sehr einfache Frau die aus dem
Osten Berlins kamen und ich will mein
glaube ich die einzigen die in normalen
Beschäftigungsverhältnissen waren und
wir soll es eigentlich bezahlen nicht
dann habe ich die angeguckt und habe
mich selber angeguckt und habe gesagt ja
okay wir
das heißt dieses Problem taucht
natürlich in vielen Zusammenhängen auf
und natürlich
was weiß ich kann der Staat da nicht
jedem hinterherschnüffeln und
herausbekommen dass der natürlich als
Klempner oder Fliesenleger oder was auch
immer
ein Vielfaches verdient dass er
obendrein nicht versteuert und für das
er also auch keine Sozialleistungen
abführt und der Leimer
das heißt eine funktionierende
Demokratie als eine freiheitliche
Gesellschaft ist auf ein gewisses Etwas
bei den Menschen angewiesen das heißt
jetzt nicht dass man das bei jedem
unterstellen kann aber man muss letzten
Endes unterstellen können dass
tendenziell 80 bis 90 Prozent so ticken
und ist das der Fall dann wächst auch
die Bereitschaft zu helfen welcher Weise
auch immer individuell indem ich was
weiß ich
irgendwelche Gelder an die Kirche gebe
oder indem ich in jedem Fall noch
anständige Steuererklärung abgeben und
ich versuche sozusagen mich da irgendwo
raus zu drücken hat man aber das Gefühl
naja sozusagen wir finanzieren damit
einen Teil der Gesellschaft der keine
Lust hat zu arbeiten dann ist schlecht
hier würde ich einmal noch mal an Herrn
Stahl zurückgeben ist es so dass 80 bis
90 Prozent so ticken ist es das
Menschenbild was sie teilen 80 Prozent
habe ich jetzt richtig verstanden der
Menschen den etwas haben also dass sie
arbeiten wollen um gemeint etwas
zuzutragen also wenn ich jetzt wirklich
mein Gefühl dass man sagen würde würde
ich mich freuen wenn es so wäre ich
denke ich auch ich glaube es nicht ja
ich glaube es leider nicht weil ich
glaube durch das was viele Jahre bei uns
versäumt wurde vorgelebt wurde und auch
gemacht wurde
das ist einfach teilweise auch viel zu
einfach gemacht wird übrigens jetzt
nicht nur auch auch diese auch deswegen
sage ich das immer wieder und ich komme
aus Berlin-Neukölln ich bin also viel
mit migrationsgrund aufgewachsen und ich
habe viele Freunde mit
Migrationshintergrund aber ich sehe
natürlich auch so ein bisschen wenn man
das so guckt jemand kommt her in unser
Land wird sofort aufgefangen ja da er
soll integriert werden oft passiert das
gar nicht es man wird überlässt sie
teilweise sich selbst und dann bleiben
sie da irgendwo hängen so und wenn man
wenn man sich das so anschaut dann dann
hat das natürlich auf andere auch eine
Wirkung warum soll ich arbeiten gehen
wenn der oder der es nicht tut und wenn
man sich das jetzt wirklich anguckt ich
habe da das letzte wieder mit jemandem
gesprochen dass ich habe mal
durchgerechnet für jemand der Bürgergeld
bekommt mit allem drum und dran ich habe
vielleicht und ich muss jeden Tag
arbeiten gehen jeden Benzin schon
unterwegs ich habe vielleicht 150 € mehr
na warum soll ich mitmachen und dann
dann zahlen Sie den noch egal ob das 500
€ Gas sind warum und das ist der absolut
falsche Anreiz und deswegen 80% in Ehren
also wenn wir wenn wir bei 50 60 % wären
dann würde ich mich freuen weil das
beschreibt natürlich den schwierigen
Zustand unserer Gesellschaft in dieser
80 bis 90% ist die Voraussetzung
funktioniert und wenn es drunter fällt
dann haben wir ein Problem
es kommt natürlich auch so weil Menschen
orientieren sich nach Vorbildern und
wenn die Vorbilder keine Leitbilder mehr
sind und mir die Bürger das Gefühl haben
von bestimmten Politikern oder von
bestimmten Teilen der Regierung
verarscht zu werden dann ist der Anreiz
das auch wirklich dem Land etwas zu
geben irgendwie auch nicht mehr da ich
höre so eine lethalgie die Menschen
vertrauen dieser Politik nicht mehr
nicht allen vielleicht aber vielen
großen Teilen der Regierung und sie
sprachen ist ja nur von unseren
Wirtschaftsminister der schon haben Sie
die perfekte moderationsüber leiden
jetzt einfach vielen Dank zu Herrn
Gräber geschafft und jetzt kommen wir
nämlich direkt zu Ihnen und es geht um
Robert Habeck als war bravourös gemacht
gut ich möchte kurz beginnen mit einem
Rückblick vielleicht erinnern sich
manche noch als Ende Februar Putin
angefangen hat in die Ukraine
einzumarschieren es war ein großer
Schockzustand im Land und es war sofort
klar das wird auch was mit unserer
Energieversorgung machen er Robert
Habeck wurde da vier Tage danach von der
ARD Journalistin gefragt ob wir denn
nicht auch noch mal den deutschen
Atomausstieg überdenken müssten weil zu
dem Zeitpunkt waren gerade drei
Kernkraftwerke frisch abgestellt drei
liefen noch die sollten zum damaligen
Zeitpunkt jetzt Ende des Jahres
abgeschaltet werden und habe gesagt zum
überraschen dieser dieser Journalistin
in die Kameras es gebe da keine denk
Tabus und er sagte er würde diese Frage
prüfen und sie nicht ideologisch
abwehren
was danach geschehen ist haben einige
Leute verfolgt es gab ein langes hin und
her und man hat es gar nicht so ganz
verstanden am Ende hat Scholz und
Machtwort gesprochen dass jetzt drei
Kernkraftwerke noch ein paar Monate
zweieinhalb länger laufen sollen das
wird uns nicht viel nützen aber immerhin
der Verdacht dass die Grünen diese
ideologisch ohne die logische Prüfung
ernst nehmen war ungefähr so glaubwürdig
wie wenn die metzgerinnung versprochen
hätte wir prüfen den Vorteil der veganen
Ernährungsweise und genau es ist auch
gekommen diese ganze Prüfung war von
vorne bis hinten eine Farce und
stellenweise waren es auch wirklich
Lügen die da stattgefunden haben und das
habe ich zusammen mit einem Kollegen der
Welt am Sonntag jetzt ganz aktuell mit
Dokumenten aufgedeckt und die Sache ist
an euch nicht zu Ende die Sache ist noch
nicht zu Ende aber erstmal kann man es
so klar sagen Robert Habeck hat gelogen
kann man ihn vielleicht in einzelnen
Aussagen kann man es sagen zum Beispiel
zum Beispiel als sie als er gesagt hat
wir haben wir haben kein Stromproblem
das war so eine Schutzbehauptung wir
müssen es nur ums Gas kümmern mit dem
Strom ist alles in Ordnung also
zusammengefasst der Bürger hat keine
ehrliche Bewertung bekommen sondern die
Ideologie von Herr Habicht sollte
gestützt werden und dementsprechend hat
er das alles so verkauft und wurde alles
so hingebogen manches verschwiegen
manches auf Zeit gespielt das war so ein
ein wirklich ein ein Taktieren alles
aber so getan als wäre es eine sachliche
Prüfung und das werfe ich Ihnen auch vor
wenn die gesagt hätten wir sind die
Grünen wir sind schon immer gegen Anti
AKW wir können das jetzt nicht machen
sonst wird Herr Trittin den
Silvesterabend werden wir ihm versauen
auf denen sich schon seit Jahrzehnten
freut hätte man vielleicht Verständnis
für gehabt hättest aber so aber so haben
sie ja so getan als wären sie jetzt auf
einmal pragmatisch und unidologisch was
sie überhaupt nicht sind das hat sie
auch dazu gebracht zu recherchieren weil
sie gesagt haben das kann ja gar nicht
stimmen dass Herr Harbeck es Ideologie
frei prüft ja
wenn man das so hört also das Politiker
die Lüge glaubt ja ehrlich gesagt eh
keiner als Bürger aber der Fall hört
sich schon schockierend an wie würdest
du ihnen einordnen naja also ich weiß
nicht ob Robert Habeck hier gelogen hat
das glaube ich nicht ich glaube sogar
dass diese Äußerungen die sie zitiert
haben aus der ARD seine tatsächlich ja
Zustand wiedergegeben hat den Robert
Habeck war glaube ich ein bisschen
offener am Anfang als seine
Umweltministerin Steffi Lemke und der
Rest der Grünen also ich glaube schon
dass er sich hat vorstellen können dass
man dann Kompromiss findet aber er wurde
dann zurückgepfiffen von Steffi Lemke
was natürlich auch viel sagt über das
Machtverhältnis innerhalb der Grünen und
es gibt da eine ganze Reihe von Gründen
Robert Habeck möchte noch was werden er
möchte irgendwann Bundeskanzler werden
er möchte kandidieren als
Spitzenkandidat er musste damit umgehen
dass ein Jürgen Trittin sie haben ihn
erwähnt natürlich vehement auf die
Barrikaden ging eine Steffi Lemke ihn
zurückgepfiffen hat die Umweltministerin
Annalena baerbock sich auf Parteitag
noch in Bonn hingestellt hat und kein
Zentimeter weiter mit uns in Sachen
Atomkraft gebrüllt hat also oder gerufen
hat und insofern musste er von dieser
Position schnell wieder runter und sagen
nein nicht mit mir was mich viel mehr
interessiert tatsächlich ob er wusste
dass er ein Kompromiss wird eingehen
müssen ob Scholz ihn über stimmen wird
als ein Parteitag seine flammende Rede
da in Bonn gehalten hat gegen die gegen
den weiter weiterlauf der Atomkraftwerke
der drei und das ist natürlich
interessant ein Punkt noch ich glaube
die Verantwortung hier einfach zu
delegieren Richtung Bundeskanzler dass
man sagt also ja ich bin es ja nicht
gewesen Bundeskanzler hat entschieden
das funktioniert natürlich nicht ne als
Wirtschaftsminister bin ich dafür
verantwortlich muss mit den Konsequenzen
leben
aber auch am nächsten Tag ein Tag
nachdem ich diesen Parteitag hatte mich
dahin gestellt habe und gesagt habe
nicht mit uns diese Entscheidung dann
hinzunehmen und zu sagen naja im Grunde
können wir damit gut leben das geht
natürlich auch nicht das zeichnet
eigentlich hätte in diesem Moment
zurücktreten müssen weil gesagt hat
Freunde ich lasse mich in dieser
zentralen Frage nicht überstimmen auch
wenn es nur drei Monate gewesen dann
machen wir jetzt hier aber auch ein
Fehler das war im Grunde war das ein
großes politisches Theater weil was ist
de facto passiert wir haben da dieses
angebliche Machtwort von Olaf Scholz da
ging es um ein einziges Kernkraftwerk
was in Niederlande Niedersachsen stimmt
das kann man nicht das kann man nicht so
sehen es gibt hier eine zentrale
Festlegung bei einem Parteitag der
Grünen in dieser Frage in sich nicht zu
bewegen und diese Frage das wird
abgeschrieben ja egal völlig egal ob
eins ist eine Grundsatzfrage die
Grundsatzfrage der Grünen und das wird
am nächsten Tag einkassiert durch ein
Machtwort des Bundeskanzlers das kann
man nicht neg schon als ein
Atomkraftwerk darstellen oder als Drive
und paar Monate das ist eine zentrale
dann ist es ja noch schlimmer wenn es
eine abgekarte ist der war ja dann ist
es ja noch schlimmer aber da freue ich
mich hat es gebraucht weil er dann für
seine eigenen Partei sagen könnte Papa
hat mich gezogen konnte
nach der Geschäftsordnung der
Bundesregierung gibt es das macht Wort
nicht das ist sozusagen ein Begriff der
ja von außen kommt sondern es gibt halt
die Richtlinienkompetenz und die sich
zeigen wie stark der Kanzler ist und ich
habe
als diese Regierung sich gebildet hat
schon mehrfach darauf hingewiesen dass
wir eine Kanzlei Demokratie waren aber
keine mehr sind weil erstmals mit einer
wirklichen 3er Koalition im Bund
natürlich sich die macht auch verlagert
weg vom Kanzler hin zum
Koalitionsausschuss und zu anderen
Gremien die dann
die dann zusammenkommen und
gewissermaßen die Kompromisse die
möglich sind Piloten so dass also die
Entscheidung des Kanzlers etwas ist was
nur im äußersten Notfall als Einsatz der
Richtlinienkompetenz gebraucht werden
kann und ich war etwas unglücklich
darüber dass es in einer so eigentlich
peripheren Frage dazu kommen musste ja
wir sehen aber die eigentliche Frage was
ich auch ganz also ich finde es auch
falsch jetzt darüber zu debattieren ob
jetzt diese zwei oder drei dann noch für
zweieinhalb Monate laufen darum geht es
nicht natürlich ist es gut dass wir
durch den Winter kommen und das Strom
jetzt damit stabiler wird und die Preise
auch gedämpft nein es geht mir um was
anderes was Fach mit den nachmiete April
was ist dann auf einmal
einfach mal ein normaler Bürger glaubt
hier wirklich einer in diesem Land außer
irgendwelche Leute die vielleicht auch
ein Pinocchio um Biene Maja loben dass
wir wirklich unsere Wirtschaft unsere
Industrie auf die wir bauen müssen mit
ohne diese
Atomkraftwerke weiter halten können ob
das wirklich irgendeiner außer nicht
irgendwelche Damen und Herren die
meistens noch nicht erarbeitet haben in
ihrem Leben also ich glaube da nicht
dran und ich kann es mir auch nicht
vorstellen dass das funktioniert dass
man mit Solarenergie Stahlwerke und und
und betreiben kann das glaube ich nicht
ja wir brauchen die Kernkraft zumindest
für eine Übergangszeit und die ist
garantiert länger als Mitte April
2023 was jetzt der große das große
Machtwort oder Kompromiss oder was immer
ist das ist ja ein Irrsinn wir haben
Deutschland hat gerade keine Strategie
wie wir die Energie versorgen unseres
Landes sicher und bezahlbar für die
nächsten jetzt beginnen Jahrzehnte
überhaupt halten und organisieren aber
keine Strategie weil dieses ganze Gerede
von von von von von von erneuerbaren das
ist alles Zukunftsmusik weil jeder weiß
es geht dauert noch lange und es geht
nicht so schlimm woher soll Strategie
auch kommen ich meine die Politiker mit
denen wir es zu tun haben werden in den
Parteien geschult als Taktiker ja sie
denken gewissermaßen um die nächste Ecke
herum aber so etwas wie Strategie gab
grenzt strategy wie die Amis das nennen
das ist nichts was ihnen in die DNA
hineingegeben wird wir haben im Prinzip
in dieser Frage durch die Bank weg ein
Problem eines strategischen Defizits in
der politischen Klasse ich bin nur auf
Zeit ja aber dann sollen überlassen
werden
heute Abend ja viele Politiker
kokettieren ja gerne mit dem Satz den
habe ich auch schon ganz oft gehört erst
das Land dann die Partei wenn ich das
aber jetzt heute von ihnen höre wie viel
Wahrheit ist denn da noch dran ist da
nicht für jeden Politiker fast erst die
Partei dann das Land oder sogar erst ich
dann die Partei dann das Land
sympathischer Kerl ich habe ihn sogar
ich saß mit ihm schon mal beim Bauernhof
im käsebauernhof also da war ich noch
lokal schon ist und er war noch Kandidat
für irgendwas es ist ja so kommt jetzt
sympathisch rüber ist auch in der
Bevölkerung in bestimmten Bereich noch
sehr beliebt aber er ist in er ist da
tragisch gescheitert er hätte die Chance
gehabt an dieser Kernkraft Frage und
zwar in dem Moment als die Netzbetreiber
gesagt haben diesen Winter kann es
Stunden geben wo wir in Deutschland den
Strom abschalten müssen in bestimmten
Stadtteilen so stundenweise ja das gab
es seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg in
Deutschland nicht damit es Strom jetzt
nicht zusammenbricht damit es nicht zum
Blackout kommt was Katastrophe wäre das
wird so
kurze Frage gehabt das wollte ich noch
zu Ende bringen es so wie Joschka
Fischer damals beim Kosovo Krieg zu
machen und auf diesen Parteitag seiner
Partei mit Verweis auf diese
Notsituationen ja die Netzbetreiber
attestiert haben schriftlich und auch
wenn
seiner Partei seine Partei zur Not
anzubrüllen und ihnen sagen eure
Anti-Atom Vergangenheit schön und gut
aber davon müssen wir wegkommen auch
wegen des Klimaschutzes
dafür war er zu feige und das wird ihm
glaube ich auf die Füße fallen wir gehen
jetzt in eine ganz kurze Unterbrechung
und sind dann zurück nicht feige sondern
frohen Mutes bis gleich
[Musik]
ernst nehmen als sogenannten Experten
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren bei viertel nach acht fünf Köpfe
fünf Meinungen vor jeder von uns hat ein
Thema mitgebracht dass sie bewegt ärgert
freut oder schockiert
so nicht Privatchat Uschi Jörg ist wir
wetten
aber niemand von den politischen
Parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur Freiheit diese
grün-roten stehen da und führen
hochtrabende Debatten über die Rettung
des Weltklimas und um die Füße rumbuseln
die Ratten das Thema ist viel zu wichtig
um es nur Update zu überlassen lass den
Leuten noch mal den Spaß wir sehen da
etwas was eigentlich fatal ist in der
Politik bei den Journalisten deren Job
ist es doch gerade abweichende Meinungen
zu finden und sie sollen den doch auch
richtig doof finden
zu Manko vielleicht einmal kurz an das
Auto das wäre ganz nett das sind
irgendwelche anorakträger aus Buxtehude
die das Gucken ich habe meinen Beifall
meine lache immer bekommen wer kümmert
sich darum niemand dit ist bald ja man
muss da ganz klar jetzt mal auch darüber
sprechen das ist einfach nicht fair ist
und nicht richtig durch die Aufgabe von
Journalismus einfach die die
Verlautbarung der Politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
wir sind zurück und machen jetzt direkt
weiter mit dem Thema von Herrn Münkler
was bewegt sie heute Abend
naja Demokratie ist ein kompliziertes
Verfahren das seine Reihe von
Voraussetzungen hat wir haben ja vorhin
schon sozusagen überarbeitet etwas in
der Arbeitsgesellschaft gesprochen und
Demokratie lebt davon dass Menschen
bereit sind sich zu engagieren für die
Demokratie wenn wir über den Untergang
und Zerfall von Demokratie entsprechend
dann gucken wir in der Regel auf äußere
Feinde oder auf innere Gegner aber wir
haben zu wenig im Auge das ist so etwas
wie ein stillzweigenden Rückzug und
vielen Bürgerinnen und Bürger aus der
Politik gibt die sich nicht mehr
engagieren die nicht mal mehr zur Wahl
gehen wenn ich meine Jugend denke wo
bunte bei Bundestagswahlen eine
Wahlbeteiligung von hohen 80
gelegentlich 90 Prozent waren und man
heute darauf schaut sozusagen es zeigt
dass Demokratie in der Gefahr steht von
innen heraus zu trocknen
und das ist jetzt im Prinzip nichts
Neues denn wenn wir mal sagen Bürger
partizipative Ordnungen also Ordnungen
in denen die ein Teilhabe der Bürger
eine Voraussetzung für das Funktionieren
das Systems es hat immer gegeben aber
sie sind auch häufig untergegangen
zerfallen an dem was
Etienne laboesie also ein der Freund von
montania
Service
freiwillige Knechtschaft genannt hat
nicht sozusagen man bekommt das Angebot
ach du musst dich ja gar nicht drum
kümmern das genügt ja wenn du ein
konsumistisches Verhalten zur Politik
hast guckst welche Partei gefällt dir
wie ein Käufer im Supermarkt schaut und
die Preise miteinander vergleicht und so
weiter und gleichzeitig sozusagen
während der Input der Bürger immer
geringer wird wird aber die Erwartung an
die Politik was sie alles so leisten hat
immer größer nicht mehr haben wir es mit
der klassischen Schere zu tun
und solche Scheren sind das Problem von
Ordnungen und das ist etwas was mich
besorgt und wie sie gesagt haben auch
bedrückt Bela spürst du diese Schere
auch ja ich habe das Buch das
Professor Münkler geschrieben hat
gelesen tatsächlich großartig ja finde
ich sehr interessant da sind auch viele
interessante historische Ministerin aber
ich glaube sie haben eine aber ich
sozusagen als kerntee ist ein Daumen
dass der Bürger sich mehr engagieren
sollte in der Politik also
medienkompetenz ist das eine und das
andere ist eben mehr Engagement aber ich
glaube Politik macht es den Bürgerinnen
und Bürgern wirklich nicht leicht sich
zu engagieren weil in vielen Parteien
ist noch das alte Verfahren der eine
protegie den einen der andere
protestiert den anderen man muss sich
hochziehen in Hinterzimmern schwer
einsaufen immer noch ja wird ja würde
man ja machen das glaube ich schon aber
die Lebenswirklichkeit von Menschen ist
einfach eine ganz andere von jungen
Menschen auch die sind autark die sind
unterwegs die wechseln alle zwei drei
Jahre ihren Wohnort auch irgendwie gar
nicht mehr in diesen Strukturen da
agieren können die aber gefordert sind
immer noch von der Politik und deswegen
Buben solche Organisationen wie Fridays
for future viele von diesen NGOs nicht
Regierungsorganisationen die natürlich
viel viel moderner Strukturen haben die
mit vernetzt sind überall die auch sowas
gar nicht voraussetzen sich da immer
hoch zu buckeln und da ist glaube ich
Politik wirklich im Hintertreffen und
wenn sich diese Strukturen nicht ändern
dann haben wir wirklich einen
Nachwuchsproblem oder die Hälfte kommt
eben aus dem öffentlichen Dienste im
Bundestag sitzen ja
also ich meine sie haben noch mal darauf
hingewiesen nicht
Regierungsorganisationen die machen es
den Leuten leicht entweder indem sie
sagen ihr habt ein gutes Gewissen wenn
ihr uns ordentlich Geld spendet und wir
machen dann da spektakuläre Aktionen
teilweise mit Industriekletterern und
anderen wie das eine Zeit lang von
Greenpeace ja praktiziert worden ist
oder auf der anderen Seite ihr klebt
euch mal irgendwo an oder werft Suppe
gegen ein
das darf man auch nicht so nur nur so
abtun weil die haben natürlich auch
Strukturen die flexiblen sind die atmen
sind wo ich mich engagieren kann wo ich
mich verletzen kann beispielsweise Junge
Union junge Liberalen die wollen ja auch
sein
kleinerst ja und ich habe da wirklich ja
nur bin ja 9 Jahre mit dabei und wir
haben sind ja in Berlin noch angetreten
ja damals mit den Freien Wählern ich
habe gesagt okay ich bringe den
Kinderschutz in Berlin rein die Wahlen
Demokratie in Berlin mit den Wahlen
lassen wir mal ganz schnell weg aber
fakt ist wenn man das so mitbekommt wie
ist denn so abläufig kommen ja nun mache
nur viel mit dem Thema Mobbing wie läuft
es ab naja also wenn du nicht Partei
treu bist und auch nicht immer zu einem
Jahr und abends sagst oder vielleicht
mal wieder Wort hast dann wirst du schon
mehr geschafft ausgegrenzt dann spricht
man manchmal mit dir und mach dir
eigentlich klar da ist der Weg ja also
zuerst kommt die Partei und dann kommst
irgendwann mal du und Idealismus und
dass man einfach vielleicht doch mal was
verändern will ist nicht unbedingt
gefragt also zu guter Soldat sein
eigentlich glaube ich eher ein Knecht
nicht oder Soldat das hört sich hier
nicht gut an für die Zukunft der Politik
und da bekommen wir zur These von Bela
under vielleicht sind wir dann etwas
fruhen gutes ja Mut zum Ende hin ja es
ist natürlich wichtig dass wir uns
politisch beteiligen das ist richtig so
aber
ja wie soll ich denn überhaupt mich
beteiligen wenn all das was ich sage was
mich stört sofort öffentlich platt
gemacht wird von
meiner großen Social Media Blase wenn
ich nur unbequeme Fragen stelle oder
ungepasste angepasste Meinung habe und
eben nicht die Power das eben so
rüberzubringen mit alles was ich sage
einfach in eine Schublade gesteckt wird
und ich mundtot gemacht werde und so
viel Beispiele gibt es wie also kann ich
gar nicht eine aufzählen aber nur ein
paar wer corona-maßnahmen kritisiert und
sie in Frage gestellt ist sofort ein
Querdenker wer fragt ob die Millionen
Flüchtlinge die sie hier sind in diesem
an sich wirklich integrieren können oder
integrieren wollen ist sofort eine
rechtsextremer oder deutsch-national
oder aus feindlich wer Fragen hat warum
die Beziehung von Bürgergeld eigentlich
so viel verdienen oder ungefähr so viel
verdienen wie Leute ja hart arbeiten ist
sofort asozial oder antisozial oder hat
was gegen diejenigen die bedürftig sind
und wer Unbehagen empfindet wenn man
diese Kunstpause macht im Gendern bei
Politiker innen der ist sowieso gegen
Frauen und
homophob das genauso und alles Mögliche
was man sich dann noch vorstellen kann
das mittlerweile doch so dass Kritik
verächtlich gemacht wird wenn sie
wirkliche Beweggründe hat auf die
Politik zum Teil keine Antworten hat
oder keine Antworten geben will und
stattdessen wird die Meinung des Gegners
diskreditiert und mit Hilfe manchmal
sogar von Gesetzen her tatsächlich auch
diese Meinung mundtot gemacht und das
darf nicht sein und das ein
grundlegendes Problem für Politik und
das müssen wir ändern wir brauchen also
den Mut derjenigen die sich artikulieren
wollen sich zu artikulieren und was zu
sagen und auch in die Politik zu gehen
und nicht nur in den extremen die diese
Haltung wiedergeben Herr Stahl sind ja
jemand der viel kritisiert werden
also grundsätzlich macht derzeit neun
Jahren machen wir da einfach kurz Bilder
in Deutschland sind immer der
gefährlicher der die Missstände
anspricht als der die mich gerne macht
und zu beantworten hat und es ist
einfach jemanden zu schaffen und sich in
Dreieck zu ziehen damit der Motor
gemacht wird dann hat man eben ja alle
gemacht ich bin seit 9 Jahren dabei man
wollte mich in die Ecke drücken in die
Ecke drücken Nazi es ist oder
populistisch ich sage immer konkret
wohin wurden sie die Farbe also alles
mögliche da wenn du dich dazu geäußert
hast dann hieß das auf einmal ja du
musst ja recht sein dann hast du auch
noch Stahl du hast also bestimmt vor
kurzem erst wieder nehmen wir den Fall
Ludwigshafen Ludwigshafen ich
hingestellt und habe gesagt ein Video
gemacht übrigens die Eltern und die
Schwester der Opfer haben mir
geschrieben sich bei mir bedankt und ich
gesagt dass sie es dass ich es
beschämend finde ein beschämend finde
dass man diesen Menschen die hier zu
Tode gekommen sind die man hier
zerstückelt hat dass man den nicht
kontrolliert erste Woche später ist Frau
Feser der Meinung da mal kurz eine Wort
zu heben wenn es aber jemand trifft der
woanders herkommt der
Migrationshintergrund dann benutzt man
jetzt sofort wieder mit dem Rechten Auge
und schiebt die Nummer in die mit der
Nazi Keule um so wenn du das dann aber
ansprichst ich mache dir schon seit
Jahren meine Kinder sind polnisch meine
Freunde es Muslimen also die können sich
Ihre naziöse sind zu entschieden aber
das haben sie natürlich probiert
entscheiden immer wenn die Politik nicht
mehr keine Argumente hat kommt sie mit
der naziole oder mit dem Populismus
Nummer aber anstatt einfach sich mal mit
dem Thema auseinanderzusetzen beste
Beispiel die Menschen hatten fragen sie
haben bestimmte Dinge fragen wollte weil
ihr Körper nein sie wurden sofort als
schwuppler verschwörungsthere drinnen
gestellt und wie kommt es jetzt raus
Lauterbach hast du noch nicht mit allem
die Wahrheit gesagt er hat sogar weil es
nicht gelogen aber jetzt redet keiner
irgendwie mehr darüber jetzt ist es
schon normal weil wir haben hier die
nächste Krise wie stolpern vor allem in
der nächsten das schöne ist ich bin ja
auch der Beweis dass man halt schon noch
seine Meinung sagen kann aber ich habe
natürlich ohne nein
hier darf ich sprechen man wird mich
doch nicht irgendwo hin holen z.B oder
zu diesem systemkonform wo sie einfach
wissen nee den gehen wir keine Bühne
hier kriegt man eine Bühne und die
Notfall natürlich eingeladen
obwohl ich sehr hart gegen
corona-maßnahmen also
ich will einfach sagen ich gebe Dir
Recht dass man halt dass man um und es
gibt ja immer wieder populäre Beispiel
Kimmich zum Beispiel geht aus dem Spiel
raus hat die schwitzt und man fragt ihn
so mittendrin und er hat einfach
öffentliche Antwort das ist seinen
Körper sofort wurde älter hast Nena
deine Namen sofort geschafft man will
ein Exempel statuieren macht das Maul
auf und wir fangen an dich zu vernichten
ich frage hier einmal ich muss immer
kommt ich hatte auch einen Lernprozess
tatsächlich auch bei Corona und die war
auch für die Impfpflicht und habe mich
dann umgesetzt ich hatte auch ein
erweiterungserlebnis ganz kurz in
München tatsächlich da war ich im
letzten Winter da war eine Demo
eigentlich angesagt war aber verboten
gegen Corona ist dann all diese Wannen
auf dem Marienplatz ist ja so schöne
Platz mit dem Rathaus und die Leute
dürfen nicht demonstrieren und standen
mit großem Abstand nebeneinander und
dachte was Murmeln die da bin
hingegangen murmelten sie das Vaterunser
einfach als als Zeichen dass sie
angehören und als Protest weil anderer
Protest nicht möglich war so weit waren
wir das schon gekommen und da habe ich
gedacht das ist auch nicht richtig
Herr Gräber welche Rolle spielen denn
die Medien weil was Bela under und
Carsten Stahl angesprochen haben
vermutlich bemerken sie auch also ich
bemerke es auch sehr stark wenn man
allein auf Twitter unterwegs ist wie
sehr erlauben Medien Meinung und andere
Haltungen also die Medienlandschaft in
Deutschland finde ich ist da an diesem
ist da sehr problematisch an dem Punkt
ich arbeite ja selbst bei Cicero ich
darf auch kurz
das ist ein ein politisches
Monatsmagazin was sich wieder da ist
aber nicht Angela Merkel die
migrationskirche Krise kehrt zurück das
ist eigentlich auch das Thema wo Cicero
damals auch so diesen Ruf bekommen hat
einen ein rechtes Magazin zu sein war
dann immer der Vorwurf also wir sind auf
jeden Fall konservativer als als andere
Zeitschriften aber nicht nur so oder auf
jeden Fall nein nein aber nur weil ich
kurz nur zur Verordnung sagen aber das
war damals die flüchtlingskrise 2015/16
wo das glaube ich auch anfing in
Deutschland diese Spaltung der
körperlichen Meinung und dass man
bestimmte Meinungen die sogar würde ich
sagen fast zumindest fast sogar eine
Mehrheit der Bevölkerung vertreten hat
dass man die versucht hat auszugrenzen
und das hat zizerin sofern auch erlebt
dass wir innerhalb der Medienbranche ich
war damals noch nicht dort ich habe es
aber selbst gelesen wurde Cicero schon
versucht auszugrenzen hat Gott sei Dank
nicht geklappt die Verkaufszahlen sind
aber gestiegen in der Zeit ganz deutlich
das ja und das ist also ich glaube wir
Journalisten müssen den Mut haben dass
wir wenn wir
Themen anpacken die der Bevölkerung
einfach wichtig sind es ist auch immer
frage wie man sie anpackt also das Buch
von Brecht und Wälzer ist gerade auch
auf eins was von allen Journalisten
eigentlich fast deformiert wurde die
Bürger mögen manchmal andere Sachen
gerne als sie Journalisten ja und da
müssen wir uns mit auseinandersetzen und
wir müssen aber auch den Mut haben das
was Kollegen über uns denken und
schreiben auch nicht ganz ernst zu
nehmen das ist dann doch eine sehr
kleine
und eine Sache die müssen sie zu Hause
mal weiterhin mögen und das ist viertel
nach acht und damit schönen Abend noch
bis Feierabend tschüss machen sie es gut
[Musik]